eisbär mama tanja die letzten vier
wochen mit ihrem neu geborenen jungtiere
in der wurfhöhle verbracht ausgiebig
kuscheln
was will man mehr eisbär babys sind sehr
sensibel
selbst in freier wildbahn werde nur etwa
ein viertel der kleinen älter als zwei
jahre alt absolute ruhe in den ersten
wochen nach der geburt ist essentiell
damit es den neugeborenen gut geht darum
wird sich auch in nächster zeit vorerst
niemand der wohl fühlen er erst in
ungefähr einem monat wenn das kleine
nicht mehr auf die ständige nähe der
mutter angewiesen ist darf es von einem
tierarzt untersucht werden so lange hält
das team aus pflegern im berliner
tierpark stellung und überprüft
stündlich ob es beiden gut geht
der natürliche lebensraum von eisbären
wird durch stetig steigende temperaturen
bedroht der berliner tierpark
unterstützt den schutz der tiere in der
arktis